à une manifestation pour le drapeau
rouge vert noir pour le lancement du
convoi pour la réparation ou encore ici
aux lorrains en soutien jeune
martiniquais convoqué à la gendarmerie
ces mobilisations voit depuis quelques
temps apparaître de nouveaux visages
nous avons rencontré quelques oeufs de
ces militants nouvelle génération un
endroit qu'ils n'ont pas choisie par
hasard
en connaissant l'histoire de décembre 59
moi ça me choque en fait ça donne là
la plus jeune a 19 ans les plus âgés 28
tous réunis par des causes communes le
combat identitaire en tête mais pas
seulement moi la cause qui tient le plus
à coeur c'est surtout la notion de
justice en fait c'est un peu dommage de
salir un plus
ce voilier cette donnée-là de justice
parce qu'en fait elle est trop qui
allait elle est falsifiée elle est à
géométrie variable c'est important en
fait deux gardiens cependant cette
justice là puisque c'est la seule chose
qui nous permet en fait de deux vivent
en société de vivre en tant qu'homme on
ne connaît pas nos héros on connaît pas
notre histoire
du coup qu'est ce que la culture qu'est
ce qu'est ce qu'être martiniquais ce
sont des questions b qui sont vus mais
c'est superficiel ça reste superficielle
quand on fouille un peu dans l'histoire
des arts scéniques et quand on se pose
des questions finalement cynique on est
tout de suite targuer de militants alors
que non c'est simplement une
martiniquaise soucieuse de l'avenir de
sa marque saturn stigmatisons je trouve
qu'il est stigmatisant parce qu il nous
éloigne beaucoup du peuple en fait tous
sont conscients de la difficulté à
mobiliser d'autres jeunes de leur âge on
n'est pas dans un monde qui incite à la
réflexion malheureusement à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui ben canton moi quand je
regarde autour de moi j'ai plus
l'impression d'avoir
[Musique]
beaucoup de personnes qui ont plus envie
de cette diversion nous avons perdu le
sens de notre histoire on va dire est
que à chaque fois que l'on voit des
choses à la télé dans les réseaux on
souhaite devenir comme eux alors qu'en
fait on prenait pas notre histoire
j'encourage les lycéens aussi à dire
qu'ils ne veulent plus qu'on leur
enseigne 6 et leurs opinions des auteurs
qui ne nous respecte pas on dirait que
quand c'est les noirs
tout d'un coup on peut nous faire tout
et n'importe quoi qu'en pense pas les
juifs à prendre qu'à des auteurs qui
était pour la colonisation qui les
considérait comme des sous humains
et quand on leur demande les modèles qui
les inspirent alors il maniait d'aller
là daniel juliette sméralda sankara
premier le drapeau pour la martinique le
chlordécone l'écologie la lutte pour les
droits des femmes
si la jeune militant sont rares les
combats à mener eux ne manquent pas